this theme music every time like a
gladdie
it's wonderful so whoever's doing that
can we please have it everyone to the
bathroom - I brush my teeth in some
circles mathematics has gotten a rep as
being well not relevant to the real
world no offense guys I'm just reading
what it says but math is an important
ingredient when working out how to blow
stuff up in the movies and that is
relevant the finite element method or Fe
M is a sexy numerical technique for
approximating complex solutions in
engineering it is widely used in the
real world
analysis of determining what will happen
to a structure when hit by another
object all blowing up Fe M was folded
into the digital molecular matter or a
DMM library it's licensed software
initially used for real time destruction
in video games it was then advanced and
upgraded for use in motion pictures the
Moving Picture Company adapted Fe M into
a visual effects destruction system
called Kali Fe M otherwise
Fe M simulations can bend for a shadow
twist and tear based upon material
properties and how the forces are
applied to those structures so hot so
hot it's real-world physics in the
digital realm and the results look
authentic and sexy of course I don't
know I'm just rolling MPC has used Kali
in almost 60 movies including x-men
first class when a super villain uses
his evil powers to make an anchor rip
through young magneto that's Magneto
of course
to been coal for the design of Kali and
Eric Parker for the development of the
digital molecular matter toolkit and to
James O Brien for his research on the
finite element method the Academy
presents each a technical achievement
award guys come get your award
so we'd like to thank the Academy and
the SCI tech investigators for
recognizing this collaborative research
that has taken place over a long time
and several institutions personally I'd
like to thank the faculty at Georgia
Tech particularly my thesis adviser
Jessica Hodgins and I'd also like to
thank all the really great students I've
had at UC Berkeley particularly Adam
Bartel who contributed to the early
development of this work and finally I
want to give a shout-out to my two kids
torn and Cayden well I just like to
thank the folks at pixel X Vic Mitch
Dave Eric and Carl my mom of course the
understanding of my kids and Lisa and
also dr. King for the SMU graphics lab
and to Peter Hirshman and for being a
Hellcats fan team with a special shout
out to Mark Williams and also to Zack
Snyder whose movie sucker punch gave us
the impetus to try this stuff out and to
all the effects CDs and lighters and
modelers whose talents have been
instrumental in demonstrating the
expressivity of these techniques thanks
a lot and thanks everybody